Speaker 1: So we knew that at some point, Kyle
Rittenhouse riding high on the heroism of his
not guilty verdict as per the right after
he killed a couple of people would somehow
come back and be used by the right in some way
that maybe he would understand, and maybe he
would not understand. But he was going to
become a tool of the right, at least until
his celebrity sort of runs out. It already may be
running out, actually, because he has now started
an organization that no one seems to care about,
and he barely seems to even understand what it
is about. We're going to look at a clip,
and you almost start to feel bad for the
kid because he's just getting used. He doesn't
know what's going on. He doesn't know, you know,
down from op and day from night. Newsweek
reports Kyle Rittenhouse launches a fund
to finance lawsuits targeting media
allies. Even that is more coherent than how
Rittenhouse explained it to Tucker Carlson on his
program, which we're going to get to in a moment.
This is a new donation fund where you can
donate and then they will hold accountable
media outlets and individuals. It's
called the Media Accountability Project,
and I guess what it will be used to do is to
finance lawsuits. Now I'm going to play for you,
the I'm going to play for you a clip of Kyle
Rittenhouse being interviewed by Tucker Carlson
on on Monday night. And Rittenhouse seems to have
no idea what's going on. I mean, just absolutely
no clue what this even is. At one point, he
nervously drinks water and looks off camera.
He seems confused, and Tucker Carlson is like
trying to help him almost explain what it is
that he's doing. And so we can come to only
a couple of conclusions, one of which is.
He has no idea what they're doing.
Or number two, he's in way over his
head. All right. Let's take a look before Kyle.
Speaker 3: Thanks so much for coming on tonight.
I can't think of many people who've been at the
receiving end of this much sinister lying from
so-called news organizations, as you have. How are
you going to respond? Well, Tucker, thank you for
having me. Me and my team have decided to.
Speaker 1: By the way, he has a team now.
That's that's even. I would love to know
who who is on his team that's advising him
Speaker 3: on the media accountability
project as a tool to help fundraise and
hold the media accountable for the lies,
they said, and deal with them in court. Oh
wow.
Speaker 1: Kyle,
that's really something. Tell us more, please.
Speaker 3: Interesting. So the idea is it may
be like the Covington Catholic kids you will be.
Speaker 1: And if you're watching, you just saw
him in a panicked way. Look off camera, OK?
Speaker 3: Suing news organizations that
maliciously lie about people who are in the news,
right? Is that the plan? Yes, sir. We're going to
be holding them accountable, Tucker. Do you feel
Speaker 1: he has no idea what he is doing and,
you know, we're laughing at it because it's so
it's impossible, you know, to avoid laughing.
But we really should almost like feel bad that
now he's clearly being taken advantage of. And
it's not even clear whether if you donate money to
this media accountability project to map the Media
Accountability Project, it's not even clear the
money really will be used for lawsuits. I mean,
remember, this is a very common right wing grift,
which is Trump did it after the 2020 election,
Trump said, Hey, I need your help. I need you to
donate, I need you to donate so that we can fund
recounts and legal challenges and flip some
states. And if you looked at the fine print,
at least half the money was not even potentially
going to be used for that. And of course,
they didn't do the recounts. They didn't do any
of it. You just you gave Trump money and Trump
did what he wanted with the money. And it very
well could be a similar thing here. But in terms
of Rittenhouse clearly being taken advantage of,
he doesn't have any idea what they're doing. He
doesn't know how they're going to be doing it.
He doesn't know how any of this stuff works.
And I am not. Ignoring the irony that Fox
here Tucker is promoting Tucker by bringing
on Kyle is promoting someone who who says, I
want to hold the media accountable for lying
when it is Fox News that for over a year has
welcomed liars about the 2020 election and
COVID and vaccines. It is Fox News who arguably
should be held accountable. And that irony?
I mean, it's not that it's lost on Tucker,
it's just completely missing, even from any
notion of a consideration that he might have. And
so this is the latest scam, and Kyle Rittenhouse
at the end of the day is probably being used. I
don't think he knows what's going on. You know,
the right loves to say Biden doesn't have any idea
what's going on. He doesn't know what he's doing.
He doesn't know what he's actually signing. Kyle
Rittenhouse has no clue what this is about. And
if you were actually subjected to real questioning
here, it would get very bad and at the end of the
day, he's basically a kid. I guess legally, he's
an adult now. I think now he's 18. But this is
basically a clueless kid being lionized because
he got away with killing a couple of people
and now is being used even further to try to
push the goals that he barely understands.
If people who are using his what I think
is going to be ultimately short lived fame